a victim of domestic violence and the
grandparents of a disabled teenager have
won a court of appeal challenge against
the so called bedroom tax it was argued
in both cases that the policy was
discriminatory the government they are
to appeal against the decision in March
on joy now by the teenager's grandfather
Paul Rutherford who looks after his
fifteen year old grandson Warren very
good afternoon to you explain why you
went to court over this well we just
thought that the whole thing was
massively unfair on us and well a lot of
other people as well so we decided that
we have to stand up and challenge it how
did this wasn't an easy decision but how
did the so-called bedroom tax affect you
and your circumstances can you hear me
I'll try again
I was asking or how does that bedroom
taxes affect you in your circumstances
you look after fifteen-year-old Warren
who is disabled and I understand you
have a another bedroom a third bedroom
so that an overnight carer can look
after him just explain how it works
well we have we have carers who come in
every day anyway to look after Warren
with us all for us and he needs looking
after 24/7 so when we get tired and you
know if nobody can look after anybody
for all that length of time not with the
level of needs that Warren has and we
need a break we get tired I'm not well
and you know when when we have the
opportunity to have the carers to come
and stay and take that strain for us for
a night a week then that's what we would
do and we don't understand why it's such
a big deal that we we're seen to be
under occupying a bungalow that was
essentially well in fact was built for
Warren in the first place well you told
you would have to give up that bedroom
or risk losing benefits what were you
told by the council
we were we were told that we were going
to have our benefits cut because the
Housing Benefit cut because the bedroom
tax had come in and we were going to
lose 14% of our ends a week and we
couldn't understand why we just didn't
understand it and we would just I don't
know we were we were in shock for a
while and eventually our story broke in
the in the national press and things
escalated and we found ourselves being
assisted to take the government to court
to try and get the law changed now
councils do have provisioned only to
make exceptions in some cases would they
not do that for you well they did that
they refused our applications three
times and then it was it wasn't till
after our car story had been on the
national news that we got the
discretionary payment but the
discretionary payments isn't a guarantee
there's no there's no security in it
there's no sort of letter that says you
will get this money next year you know
we don't know the government could stop
giving that money to the council's next
year for all we know it's not it's not a
secure position to be in not when we've
got a child like Warren whose whole life
is depending on on how we are able to
look after him and it's enough of a
strain as it is without the added stress
of being unsure we're not feeling secure
in what was our own home just tell us
what kind of a difference it does make
to your lives to Warren's life having
that extra bit of help
it's a massive difference because
without that without the help I don't
think we could actually look after him
because he does need looking after all
the time if if he chooses he won't go to
sleep tonight there's nothing we can do
to make him oh he can be awake all night
all day
we have to carry on with all the
everyday jobs like shopping and cooking
and cleaning washing and still look
after Warren and in the end you just
can't sustain that level of care on your
own and it's hard to ask for help but we
have to and we've been provided with the
help to care for Warren and we couldn't
understand still don't why the
government can't see that and just give
us the help that we need it's not like
we don't think we're asking for very
much there's a lot of people out there
as well who've had who are in our
position who've been told that they
can't have a discretionary housing
payment and that is people who are in
exactly the same circumstances as
ourselves and for that reason if nothing
else all people in our situation should
be exempted from the bedroom tax rather
than rely on discretionary payments
which the word itself says it all is
discretionary so it's out of our hands
we just want the peace to know that we
can look after Warren without the stress
of no of worrying about whether or not
we'll be able to stay in the house we'll
have to move whether he'll have to go
into care him going into care is
something that our lives are dedicated
to preventing and we don't want we will
fight anybody who makes that look like
it might have to happen including as
we've done now we'll fight the
government it doesn't matter it's Warren
who's the priority and all the other
disabled kids disabled people and
anybody else who's affected by this
policy you have won today Paul but the
government says they're going to appeal
against it what would you say to
ministers who are listening I'd say they
have no idea what they're doing and I
would say that they don't they should
look closely they should look at Warren
they should look at myself and they
should ask themselves what they are
doing what do you hope to achieve by
this by
you know what is the ultimate aim to
grind us down even further is that what
you want to achieve do you want Warren
to go into care do you want me to have a
nervous breakdown or my wife who you
know it's like what do you want or do
you want us the citizens of your country
to be able to just live our lives and
give this man young man the best that we
can that's what we want to do and it's
over to them what they want to do now
Paul Rutherford thank you for your time
and also the Lawrence for joining us
today no I think you've summed it up
thank you very much